good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight let's enter Fantasyland
for a moment let's pretend for a sec
that our country had a news media that
was interested in bringing you the news
not in lecturing you about your moral
inferiority you're so bad we're lying to
you and transparently obvious ways
January 6 was an Insurrection guys
or even enforcing you to repeat whatever
childish slogan they've come up with
this week Vladimir Putin is a war
criminal okay trans women are women all
right say it or else
let's imagine instead that we live
somewhere completely different in a
country where the media felt obligated
to tell you what was actually happening
in the world and why it matters what
stories would we be talking about right
now if we lived in that country we'll
hear the first two earlier this month
Iran and Saudi Arabia the two most
significant powers in the Muslim World
announced that after generations of
proxy wars and snarling hostility to one
another they will be resuming diplomatic
relations peace has broken out between
blood enemies as recently as last year
very few would have thought that could
happen and now it has happened and it's
happened and here's a significant thing
from an American perspective it's
happened because China not the U.S state
department but the Communist Chinese
government brokered the deal
the world's largest atheist state has
halted religious conflict between two
theocracies
did you see that coming probably not but
there's more
yesterday China's president XI turned up
in Moscow to announce a new partnership
with Russia going forward Russia will
supply much of China's oil and natural
gas Vladimir Putin also agreed to use
Chinese currency in trade with Asia
Africa and Latin America once again holy
smokes
as with the iran-saudi summit very few
people imagined anything like this could
happen just 18 months ago quote change
that hasn't happened in a hundred years
G said is coming and we are driving this
change together
now what change was she talking about
well the end of American global hegemony
the end of the US dollar as the world's
Reserve currency for a hundred years he
got it right since the close of the
first world war the United States has
been the preeminent Nation on Earth for
40 of those years we are locked in a
cold war with the Soviet Union of course
but at no time no matter what they may
have claimed was there ever really a
question about who is the most powerful
country we were the most powerful
country it was the American era that era
just ended a little over two years into
Joe Biden's presidency
but amazingly no one in this country
seems to notice that it happened that
story is not leading the news tonight
instead we're arguing about whether or
not to arrest Donald Trump for a fake
crime to keep him from running for
president again
over at the White House our senile
president just gave some sort of Medal
to a sitcom actress presumably for her
bravery you read those scripts so boldly
CNN is covering that story like it's the
moonwalk
on Twitter meanwhile people seem excited
that our vice president has sent a
letter to a transvestite Tick-Tock star
called Dylan Mulvaney who is famous for
dressing like a six-year-old girl Kamala
Harris is very proud of him
that's the news we're getting it is
Weimar but Dumber
meanwhile the world Beyond moaning Joe
is changing faster than any time and
well as chairman G correctly noted about
a hundred years
none of these changes will make life
better for your grandchildren
but since many Americans don't even know
they're happening the outcry here has
been limited to a few insightful but
deeply frustrated bloggers on social
media They See Clearly what's happening
no one else seems to it's driving them
insane
there are still people in this country
for example who seem to believe that the
so-called climate agenda is actually
about the climate or about the
environment of the Earth or something
and not a coordinated effort by the
government of China to hobble the U.S
and the west and take its place as the
leader of the world which of course is
exactly what's going on it's pretty
obvious when you think about it but most
people don't get a chance to think about
it because the propaganda is just too
thick it's unceasing it never ends
here's the latest on the front page of
papers around the country the head of
the United Nations demanding the United
States blow up its own economy otherwise
the world will end humans are
responsible for virtually all Global
heating over the last 200 years
the rate of temperature rise in the last
half century is the highest in 2000
years
concentrations of carbon dioxide are at
their highest in at least 2 million
years
the climate Time Bomb is
East
so when someone who knows nothing about
science whose job it is to act as a
proxy a puppet of the Chinese government
starts wagging his finger in your face
claiming scientific expertise and
telling you what to do with your economy
at the very least you should pause for a
moment and you should also remember that
the United Nations has been saying
pretty much the same thing since at
least 1989. that's the year that the
Associated Press reported that and we're
quoting a senior U.N environmental
official says entire nations could be
wiped off the face of the Earth by
rising sea levels if the global warming
trend is not reversed by the year 2000.
that was 34 years ago happy to report
we're still here so as the science
changed well apparently it has not that
anyone will acknowledge that but the
shouting remains exactly the same and
the AP doesn't seem to have archives it
can check to find out have we written
the story before so they just keep
writing the same story two days ago they
wrote this and we're quoting Humanity
still has a chance close to the last to
prevent the worst of climate change's
future harms a top United Nations panel
of scientists said Monday but doing so
requires quickly slashing nearly
two-thirds of carbon pollution by 2035.
press
a quote from the U.N Secretary General
again not a scientist a puppet of China
but
pretty good at slogans and we're quoting
humanity is on thin ice and that ice is
melting fast
just moving the dates around
not really actually because if you read
it closely if you took a look at the
un's entire report and actually we spent
the day doing that there are big
differences in how they plan to solve
global warming this time the plan is
much more explicit make the West the
United States states primarily but also
Western Europe blow up its own economy
while China the fastest growing economy
in the world
doesn't have to do anything
and in fact they're not doing anything
China is currently building well two new
coal plants every week every week
not good at math but that's like 104 a
year that's a lot of coal plants how
many are we building in week zero pretty
weird for a country committed to
fighting climate change
well the report says that compared to
Eastern Asia North American countries
have a 33 percent greater obligation how
do you measure obligation is there a
scientific scale for that but a greater
obligation 32 percent more to accelerate
spending on quote mitigation investment
flows to quote limit global warming
okay
okay that's an obligation now if you
were to go by like real numbers you
might notice that China's carbon
emissions today are more than double our
carbon emissions here in the United
States
so we're spewing less carbon they're
spewing a lot more carbon but we have to
spend more because we have a moral
obligation because why that's not
explained but later in the report the
United Nations does say this quote
actions that prioritize Equity climate
justice social justice and inclusion
lead to more sustainable outcomes
co-benefits reduced trade-offs support
transformative change and Advance
climate resilient development adaptation
responses are immediately needed to
reduce Rising climate risks especially
for the most vulnerable Equity inclusion
and just transitions are key to progress
on adaptation and deep societal
Ambitions for Accelerated migration
try not to use a swear word on TV but I
think we know what that is
it's BS
the report continues we need quote
meaningful participation and inclusive
planning informed by cultural values and
Indigenous knowledge indigenous
knowledge now how much of that that's
directly from the UN report how much of
that sounded to you probably not a
credential scientist
a person with common sense how much that
sound like science all of it says CNN
all of it
humanity is on thin ice and that ice
melting fast that warning courtesy of
the United Nations Secretary General
made in tandem with a brand new United
Nations report labeling the planet a
ticking Time Bomb it is worse than we
ever thought it was going to be and the
time is ticking in order to defuse this
climate bomb the climate Time Bomb is
ticking that's according to the U.N
intergovernmental panel on climate
changes report there's no such thing as
climate alarmism anymore the the time
bomb is ticking the new U.N report warns
the climate Time Bomb is ticking and the
world is running out of time to avoid
catastrophe
there's no such thing as climate
alarmism anymore nothing you say can be
too extreme it doesn't matter that's
science
for the Chinese it's just so easy how do
you win a war without fighting by
getting your adversary to kill himself
well how do you convince a strong
self-respecting powerful country like
ours that has ruled the world for 100
years to do that turns out it's pretty
easy you take a collection of dumb
desperate people in middle age hoping to
keep on to their stupid TV jobs you add
scripts and some hairspray and they just
repeat the lies for you and then all the
people in the countries wrote an idea
that's exactly right we got to do that
respect indigenous knowledge stop
driving our cars
and the amazing thing it's kind of
working
so what exactly is the science behind
all this well on sub stack actual
scientists now reside a political
scientist called Roger Pilkey did a deep
dive on where these people got the idea
that the world will end if temperatures
jump 1.5 degrees Celsius
that's the globally accepted goal
according to the AP well it turns out
that globally accepted goal originated
in a newspaper advertisement and a draft
paper that was not even peer-reviewed
now it's in the Paris climate agreement
That's The Power of marketing
but what's the point of course what's
the point of the marketing it's to
destroy one civilization to be
supplanted by the next civilization
unfortunately we're the one being
destroyed or that is destroying itself
and no one at the UN by the way cares
about the data where it came from
because the real goal has nothing to do
with the environment of course duh look
at the pollution if you cared about the
environment this is a tough time to live
but ever since Julian Huxley took over
UNESCO in the 1940s pushing
malthusianism the idea that the world's
overpopulated has been the dominant way
of thinking for the people in charge
except with respect to their own
families they have as many kids as they
want but you're not allowed to and that
leads to moments like the one we saw a
month ago where the Harvard historian
Naomi oreskis wrote an op-ed in
Scientific American entitled 8 billion
people in the world is a crisis not an
achievement
well if you're one of those 8 billion
that seems like hostility if some chick
is writing a piece in a science magazine
about how your existence is bad
that might make you nervous right
it should
and it may explain why these people
oppose
nuclear energy which seems like a
solution but they're against that too
so it's not really about carbon
emissions is it it's about hurting
people specific people they think there
are too many people
and this view is very widespread that's
why the leaders of the democratic party
are always in your face telling you to
get an abortion hurry up and get an
abortion it'll help the GDP
doesn't hurt of course that getting rid
of fossil fuels would mean a lot of
Democratic Party leaders will get a lot
richer their donors certainly will the
ones in the renewable industry it also
means a ton of money for people with no
skills at all like Jen granholm who's
now the energy secretary who owns stock
in these green energy companies while
she was in office
it's also corrupt it's unbelievable and
they're in your face there's no such
thing as climate alarmism shut up and
accept it this would explain why Joe
Biden campaigned on ending fossil fuels
and bringing about economic Devastation
for millions of Americans back in 2020.
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal and fracking in a
Biden Administration
no we would we would work it out we
would make sure it's eliminated and no
more subsidies for either one of those
either any fossil fuel no more subsidies
for fossil fuel industry no more
drilling on federal lands no more
drilling including offshore no ability
for the oil industry to continue to
drill period but I want you to look at
my eyes
I guarantee you I guarantee you we're
going to end fossil fuel and I am not
going to cooperate around okay
imagine living under the rule of people
like that imagine living in a system
where we with a straight face ask
someone who's never had a real job in
his entire life who has no idea where
electricity comes from probably can't
even change a light bulb at this point
but our energy policy
and then taking his answer seriously and
what do you get when you do that and
apparently we did 81 million votes he
got more than Obama really shut up and
accept it well the result is now a
strategic petroleum Reserve maybe the
most valuable thing the United States
government owns is depleted and Russia
which we say we hate is now once again
one of the most important energy
suppliers in the world
Meanwhile your energy prices went up at
Double the rate of inflation last year
so why are we looking at here well there
are people with economic agendas
benefiting from solar panels and the
wind farms that kill endangered species
uh and they're the illiterate cultists
in Academia who are just for this
because they're for it
is if to prove that point Greta
thundberg who just deleted a tweet from
five years ago saying the world's gonna
end in five years is about to get an
honorary degree from the University of
Helsinki this is a girl who made a
living by not attending school so what's
the degree in what's not science not
climatology it's theology but the real
agenda of course is much bigger than any
of that it's the great Global
reshuffling that is going on now
beneath the notice of most Americans
we're going to wake up one day and
realize we're not in charge
and this is
part of the reason
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight